the way you eat is also important
reducing the snacking time less meals
giving yourself at least 12 hours
overnight ideally 14 is a good way for
your gut to repair itself and enhance
eating more slowly we all eat too fast
and one in five American meals are
consumed in the car you know learn to
try something new there are different
people are you an early morning person a
lay money person try skipping breakfast
try changing your breakfast from a high
carb one to a high fat one see how you
feel don't accept that everything's the
same for everybody the more we can all
experiment and understand our bodies the
better we get to understand food and
live with it this is really important
and that small changes to your nutrition
can have massive effects you know via
your gut microbiome if we get it right